Okay now that we talked about what
we want in a trusted computing base,
we want it to be trustworthy,
we want it to be high assurance and
we said even in a follow
designed principals.
So let's talk a little bit about how
do we build a trusted computing base.
Well first of all, if we claim it
to be a trusted computing base,
it has to implement certain
key requirements or
features that you associate
with a secure system.
In other words, it must implement
certain security Relevant functions.
Certain functions that are important for
securing access to resources.
So, for example,
it has to address authentication.
If it doesn't address authentication
we will know who's making a request for
a resource that is
protected in the system.
It has to do access control.
Access control for whatever resources
that we have, could be files,
could be other kind of
objects that we have.
When it comes to access control,
we talked about two different
kinds of access control.
We talked about
mandatory access control.
It may support that.
It may support labels that can be
used to implement the BLP model for
example or some of the other mandatory
access control models that we discussed.
It has to support
discretionary access control.
So somebody who creates a resource
that has some control over
who can access it and
who cannot access it.
The basic idea here is that
when you say I'm going to build
a trusted computing base, the first
question you have to think about is,
what are the core functions
I have to provide?
Some core mechanisms that have
to go into the system and
these are some examples of those.